with so many aspects of our lives
shutting down it can be reassuring to
see some things keep going first mission
for the United States space force a
successful mission on Thursday launched
from Cape Canaveral in Florida with a
one point four billion dollar
communications satellite onboard other
parts of the space industry though are
dealing with astronomical headaches just
like everybody else we understand that
the International Space Station may
possibly be the safest place on earth
over the next few months the next men to
leave the planet have been under heavy
quarantine in Russia's Star City forced
to say goodbye to their families several
weeks ahead of schedule that's to ensure
they don't bring Cova 19 to the
International Space Station next week
it's really interesting it's none like
any other time in our in our lives as a
generation really right like to me it
this is goes into where were you when
JFK was shot where were you when you
landed on the moon and where were you
when coronavirus was happening and I'll
have my own interesting story to tell in
in years to come for nearly a decade the
US has relied on Russia to fly its
astronauts into low-earth orbit but that
will change in a few weeks if all goes
according to plan go on to for grabs
sample container NASA and the private
American aerospace company SpaceX say
the launch of a crewed mission will go
ahead and mid to late May regardless of
the pandemic back on earth there's a lot
riding on the mission giving the u.s.
the capacity to send its own people into
space once again timelines for other
missions will certainly have to be
pushed back NASA's new Orion spacecraft
is scheduled to take the next man and
first woman to the lunar surface in 2024
NASA is also building the world's most
powerful rocket to get them there and
then hopefully to Mars but the plant
producing the rocket is just outside of
New Orleans which has one of the highest
rates of new coronavirus infections in
the world
the agency shut nearby rocket production
and testing facilities on march 19th
than others across the country to
protect its workforce when you work on a
rocket a lot of people have to work very
close to each other and that could have
that could have really spread quickly
it's even affecting spacecraft already
millions of kilometres from Earth the
European Space Agency has put eight of
them in what's known as hibernation mode
because of reduced staffing and has
suspended its launches indefinitely even
with delays on the next-generation of
their spacecraft NASA astronauts are
busy performing a different public
service sharing advice on how to cope
with isolation at home after they
survive the isolation of space some of
it is just connecting you know reaching
out and doing a video call with family
and friends or working on a project you
know when I was on orbit I do crossword
puzzles with my boys over a video chat
advice that we can all use right now no
matter where we are in the universe
Andrew Chappell al Jazeera